hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie and today we're going to
continue on with what we're doing
yesterday with graph QL and WordPress
and react but I got a pull request from
Harshit so we're gonna go over that so
we have I have on a on a separate branch
right now that pull request and I
haven't merged it yet partly because
I've been working on other things and I
didn't really have time to but I did
have time to start to go through this
pull request a bit and it looks great
I'm just trying to get my head around
what's going on because I've never
worked with this before so just to sum
up the pull request what he's done is
he's taken out Redux and instead we're
just using Apollo to work with our with
graph QL and it's interesting
I'll show you so we have some new dev
tools stuff going on here with our
Apollo tools but if we go back to our
Redux you can see we actually have the
state showing up here like it would
normally so in the description for the
pool request this is pull request one in
the github repo that's linked in the
description if you want to check out
what was changed but Harshit mentions
that there is basically redux is being
used by apollo anyway behind the scenes
so that makes sense so I want to check
this out and I want to get a
opinion on you know whether or not is
this is this the best route to go just
to completely cut out Redux and work
with Apollo and because I I don't know
because I haven't worked with it before
and let me lay out before before we do
our first session and basically the
first session is going to be going
through some of this code before we even
start to code anything else just so that
we're all on the same page but what I'm
thinking is would there be some reason
down the road that we would want to use
redux as well and if that's the case
should we try to incorporate redux right
off the bat or should we wait and if we
need it then bring it in so that's kind
of what I'm thinking about right now
so I'll give everyone a chance to you
know think about that if you've if
you've worked with with redux and Apollo
before just let me know or if it's
better just to go with Apollo and and if
we can accomplish the same things with
Apollo that we could with redux then I
just need to learn how to do it like
that then okay cool all right Harsha
says it's not that complex of an app
you're right yeah it's not really
complex I think I mentioned yesterday
it'd be I'd like to add a little bit
more complexity to it but for now it is
and really we're just getting data about
posts from WordPress and we're
displaying those posts and then
everything else is really just we want
to allow users to search for posts and
we want them to be able to filter posts
based on categories based on date and
then beyond that we just want to display
those posts in different ways which
really doesn't have much to do with with
our store or where the data is that's
more of just make creating different
views and putting that same data into
the views
different ways okay all right let's let
me bring over my my timer or is it that
all right let's bring over my timer I'm
gonna start this Pomodoro timer so we'll
do 25 minutes of coding or at least code
review and then I'm going to take a
five-minute break answer any questions
that are in the live chat and then we'll
come back and do another 25 minute
session we'll probably just do two
Pomodoro sessions of coding today we'll
see how it goes but we'll do at least
two and let's see it looks like my
analytics may be off occasionally
they're off at the very beginning of
this dream but it looks like we have a
lot fewer people than we normally do so
let me know did you all get a
notification occasionally if I if I
don't schedule the stream until later in
the day sometimes the notifications
don't go out normally it looks like I
got one on my phone but anyway I still
have to do work whether or not anybody's
watching so we're definitely gonna
continue okay cool Kevin's here hey
Kevin and Kevin did get a notification
so alright okay awesome so I see some
more people in here now yeah my
analytics are definitely off because
there are more people talking in the
live chat hadn't been registering on the
the YouTube analytics so I'm not gonna
stress this for now I do want to
remember to start my and Rock server so
I'm going to do that right now and I'll
copy the link in so in the live chat
there's now a link you can click that
and then you can see in real time all
the changes that we're making you can
inspect it in dev tools and
it'll be a lot easier to kind of see
what's going on all right so let's go
through some of some of the code if you
want to look at it more on your own like
I mentioned earlier check out who
requests one in the github repo that's
linked in the description and then
you'll be able to see the explanation
and exactly what was changed but I'm
going to go through some things let's
see let's get rid of I'm gonna get rid
of some of the stuff that is not there
anymore it's not needed I think this one
also is not needed so big the big thing
to notice right off the bat is we have
no more actions or reducers okay so if
we're not using redux we don't need any
of that Redux stuff so that's all gone
we also don't need this
this API utility okay so that's gone as
well you'll notice that the components
are all much smaller and let's go back -
here we go alright so we do have a few
things and I guess I'll start with this
one because it's up here not sure if
it's the best order but so we have a
graph QL folder now and within that we
have mutations which there's nothing in
this file yet but under our queries
under posts you can see just like
yesterday whenever we we put in a query
structure - just like this well I don't
think we had the featured image in there
but basically we structured I like this
to get the data back so now we have two
queries that are built out here so
single post query to get a particular
post so we're passing in an ID here and
then we get all posts here so we're just
asking you know for all the posts
I mean this is so far I haven't used
graph QL very much at all but I'm liking
this you can look at this and
immediately know all right I know
exactly what data I'm gonna get back
that's cool it's not always so apparent
with the REST API
you know the WordPress REST API I could
look at the URL that I'm putting in and
know that I'm getting posts but I
wouldn't necessarily know you know all
the other stuff that I'm getting unless
I'm already familiar with what I get
back from that API so I really like that
it makes it you know easy to know
immediately what's going on and let's go
here we have our Apollo client so where
as yesterday we had a lot of this stuff
in our app dot J's file now we just
import all of that in so it cleans up
the Abkhaz file a bit we imported in
we're still we're bringing this in in
the same way but we no longer are
passing in the store so other than that
I mean well with the exception of
removing all the stuff that pertain to
Redux it's pretty much the pretty much
the same here so now let's actually
check out our home component where we're
displaying some of this stuff so if you
notice on the on the site I'm not sure
where the site said I had it up I'll
have to oh it's a funny I way too many
things open on my other screen here all
right here we go so the site now it's
actually it's pulling data from
somewhere else not from from my web site
so that's why it's all different but you
can see for this home page it's just
displaying all the posts right so it's
using that first query that gets all the
posts and then if we click inside it
then it takes us to a single post page a
post detail page that uses that second
query that passes actually passes the ID
which we can see the post ID here and
gets the information all right so that's
what's going on
in terms of how it how it looks and
here's the code for that
okay that's interesting I didn't notice
it like I said I didn't really have a
chance to go through everything in here
current user okay so it looks like this
is in here for when we implement the
login system so probably correct me if
I'm wrong
Harshit but this is probably not doing
much of anything right now since we
don't have a login system hooked up this
is not the good
wait harsh it says this isn't the code
okay you know what maybe he's still
displaying the the code the previous
code let me reopen that there we go
that's it okay cool yeah that that
looked a little odd I guess I had put
that in there yesterday and didn't
remember that I did it okay I think that
was the example I copied and pasted from
somewhere okay thanks for letting me
know about that
okay so here's what's going on now so
we're bringing in graph QL and this from
what I understand and just the
disclaimer here I'm seeing a lot of this
for the first time so this is definitely
going to be a learning episode for this
stream here but from from what it looks
like is we're bringing in graph QL here
and we're calling that query get all
posts and then what I'm assuming happens
because otherwise I I don't know how the
data would be displayed is that when we
do that those posts end up getting into
here's props
so this props data and then under posts
we'll have all our posts so correct me
if I'm wrong but I I mean that just
doesn't seem like obviously it has to be
getting into props somehow so I think
that's it so we can determine what query
we want so I think I close that window
out but if you remember we had our
queries so get all posts that's that's
what we're using down here
and cool I like that so added a little
loading thing so if there are no posts
we're loading if there are posts then we
actually display the posts I like that
that's nice you can see really clean
definitely clean things up a lot so I I
like this so I still need to learn more
you know to to work with it myself but I
do really like this the other one that
will have some code with them let me
okay and we're bringing in that query
and okay so we're using the constructor
bind okay we're doing the loading thing
up here like this alright so down here
we're doing a single post detail but
then options match okay so we're
grabbing the ID from our match params
we're passing in like that okay
I'm gonna check out the the other file
here I want to check these out side by
side why did that not work
all right so something's up with with
Adam from so I guess I'm not gonna do
this side by side right now
all right that's that's interesting to
me that that it gets passed in like this
I would have thought that we would have
passed it in more like a regular
function but instead it's like the
second argument of this graph QL hmm all
right so that's something I'll have to
I'll have to look up more but basically
I mean that's that's it that's pretty
much all that was added to be able to
get everything to display like you know
like you can see on the site if you go
to the the link posted earlier so let's
forget to start my timer so I'm just
gonna keep an eye on the time for now
and then I'll start the timer for the
next one let's see
all right she's checking the live chat
briefly okay all right so I guess what
what I'd like to do now then is try to
hook this up with as much as cool as all
this these comic books are I would like
to hook this up with the data that we
are working with yesterday and also at
some point we need to we need to hook
ups either a custom post type or if we
can stick with posts we need to have
some custom fields for the posts so
we're gonna work on that I don't know if
we'll get into that today but let's get
some data in there some of the other
data in there and I don't know I mean I
guess if if I can wrap my head around
how things are working and there's
really no reason why we couldn't start
to actually build this out a little bit
more with with a UI that's closer to
what it's actually gonna be like so so
let's start on that I need to grab let's
see I believe that or Apollo client is
where we can put this in yep that's it
so there you go Jessie why google.com
slash graph QL and let's see what we get
so far I just get a lot of loading
loading all right so do nothing so far
let's let's see what's going on whoa
fail to fetch that's interesting
hmm
it's my site down I'm just going on
I must say still working
hmm
okay for some reason this is not working
that's good that's really good
let me make sure this plugin is still
active yeah okay yeah so I'm not really
sure not sure what the problem is
let's go let me do here let's find our
queries you know opposed let's try to
run this here okay yeah we're still not
getting anything
let's run this again interesting
hmm
okay maybe
oops it's not what I wanted when it
posed alright for those edges
hmm
interesting
okay well we could just go back to using
the other one for now and then I can
look into what's going on that'll
probably be the best thing to do for now
so let me
let me just go back let's go back to
this
and
sorry
yep
okay so that is working
let's try to get some categories as well
some wonder you know pose
let's try to make another query and
let's say categories let's see what we
need for category there we go categories
I just know
mmm
you see
maybe there are no categories in here so
that's why I'm not getting categories
hmm
okay that's what hard she said no
categories okay well um we are going to
need categories at some point so we can
grab this and at least make it who hard
says otherwise I would have built that
too for you thanks I appreciate that
it's probably good that there's some
stuff that I still need to build that
way I'll learn I'll learn how to do it
too so let's put that in so we have our
posts jeaious
so let's make a categories dodge ass and
and then we could make I mean we won't
really be able to test it out because
there are no categories but once I
figure out what's going on with the
WordPress my wordpress site and why I
can't get data from it
then we can test it out with categories
but if we use this as an example I'm
sure it'll work when the time comes
so let's inquiries let's make a new file
we're going to call this categories and
oops I wanted to see those let's just
copy everything paste it in there and
then we'll also get get this again and
we'll paste it in instead of instead of
this one
get all categories and categories and I
guess we can we can also get a single
category I I don't know that we would
need to I'm not gonna put that in now
because I I can't really see a case
where we would need to get a single
category by ID so I'm going to leave it
off for now
and let's just export this really I want
more than the ID let's at least try to
get the slug and what else I guess I'm
not sure if the it would be category
name or if it would be category title
because I haven't seen that data
okay let me keep an eye all right so
it's it is time for me to do a five
minute break for question and answer so
let me do that now and I'm going to
scroll up to the top of the live chat
here and just go down through see if
there's any questions I can answer
okay so Rolando would like to know of a
simple tutorial to begin learning reacts
so there are some good YouTube videos
that are introductions to react learn
code Academy is a YouTube channel that
has some good in sure to react videos
they are a few years old but the the
general concepts of react are still the
same even though maybe some of the
syntax will be a little bit different
you know in the current version also I
think there are some react videos on the
free code camp channel sorry it seems
like this time of day I'm just I'm
always yawning no matter what even if I
get enough sleep or enough caffeine in
this yawning yeah like what else else is
good for reacts if you like kind of like
the in-browser tutorial stuff code
Academy has has yeah they have an
in-browser tutorial I haven't checked it
out for a while I did it when it first
came out so they may have more than one
out now so those are the ones that just
come into my mind
okay
okay Marco asked how is this loading
page being displayed and I think we I
think I showed that could but let's
we'll take a look at it again in case I
didn't really explain it but you can see
here is where the loading takes place so
it's just simply checks to see if if
they're posed so basically if if there
aren't any posts yet in this props data
posts then it's displays loading
otherwise if posts exists then it
displays everything so initially when
everything loads there won't be post
right because we still have to tell
graph QL to use this query to get the
data but then once the data comes in
then it gets put into props then it will
it will display so that's where the
loading is coming in John lund said you
sound a bit English Jessie I like I've
never even been to England so I don't
know but I actually really like to watch
a few English youtubers that have
cooking shows
maybe it's rubbing off on me I don't
know but I'm not now in English I would
say if there's any influence on my my
accent my pronunciation of words it
would probably be a Pittsburgh influence
because I live pretty near to Pittsburgh
but I know if anybody has ever been to
Pittsburgh you know they they have quite
a few words that are very unique to
Pittsburgh and I'm not I don't usually
use the Pittsburgh slang terminology but
I grew the people that live right across
the street from me growing up were like
they definitely had the Pittsburgh
accent used all the Pittsburgh words so
it could have rubbed off on see our Toro
says asked you know you took all the
Redux code up yeah so well I didn't
harsh it did in his pool request and
that's what we're checking out right now
but yeah so it looks like we're not
we're not gonna use Redux we don't
really have to
okay all right kevin says by the way
that gql stuff is a tagged template
string okay let's check that out because
I did wonder about that all right Shh
all right I'm not familiar with tagged
template string so I may have to look
that up interesting
cool alright so my five minutes is up
so I'll come back to the live chat and
go through the rest of it after our next
coding session but for right now let's
go back so we should be save that and
cool all right I just scrolled down to
the bottom of the live chat now I'm just
gonna mention the last two comments
before I start the next session here
because they're awesome so haha
checkpoint says you guys are amazing and
I appreciate that thanks for saying that
and then Silas has finally caught your
livestream so awesome really glad that
you could catch the livestream it's
awesome so I feel free to ask any
questions or contribute in the live chat
ok oh I did I do have to ask a question
I told a friend of mine that I would ask
if anyone knew of any good beginner
resources or books on on a VBA so I
guess they're gonna try to learn that so
anyway let me know I don't know if
anybody knows but I have no idea of any
resources on it so he had he had asked
me about it two days ago and I forgot to
ask yesterday so if anybody knows let me
know otherwise you don't worry about it
I'm sure it'll be all right he's smart
guy all right
so at this point I don't really want to
spend a lot of time troubleshooting my
wordpress site I don't I don't really
think that would be we're allowed to do
at this point especially since I'm not
at first I'm just gonna do a little bit
of research so that's not really not
good - like what somebody else Google I
don't think that's that's very fun so
let's do some some UI stuff which maybe
we should bring in material UI so if
you're not familiar with material you
I'll bring it up so material - you i.com
for our last project we used this
version of material UI the old version
and this is simply a framework of react
components that follow the material
design guidelines but I'm thinking
yesterday I did some do some reading of
the documentation of the newest version
of material you I and I think I think we
may use this they have some they have
some good stuff in here so we're gonna
try to use this I know last time we
tried to use this that it just came out
and it didn't really go so well but I
think at this point there should be
enough information out there that I can
that I can get at or actually let me see
okay harsh you're just putting a live
chat you need to downgrade WP graph QL
okay is that gonna fix the issues that
we're having okay I wish looked up a
little bit farther
oh okay so it looks like there's some
sort of breaking change all right what's
worth a shot to check this out
WP graph QL github see they have a
change
okay
all right this looks like maybe this is
our problem I request an Authenticator
for three session
hmm
okay releases all right so miss that
okay
it's just thing okay
I forgot to start it again better set my
timer let me start the timer for 25
minutes all right so I'm actually I'm
not going to reset or go back to a
previous version right now there's
basically I'd like to stick with the
most current version and then just do
whatever I need to do to my WordPress
installation to make this work obviously
there's something you can do to make it
work because it's working with you know
the demo WordPress installation so I
think I'd rather do that and be able to
stick with the newest version but this
may point me in the right direction to
see what I need to do but for now let's
let's bring this in thank you
Kevin just reminded me that my face was
covering the timer again thanks for that
I'll get used to that eventually
I just extremes
without my face being there for so long
now I just can't can't seem to remember
this there I hope I don't make any weird
faces because I forget that you all can
see me so let me know if I'm doing
something strange okay
haha oh man okay so this is the problem
so Harshit says the demo uses the older
version that's why it works
haha okay that makes so much sense now
all right we know what I'm gonna do
actually at some point in the maybe I
might not get to it today but hopefully
you know before the next stream on
Monday I'm gonna reach out to the
creator of this plugin so the the person
who created this plug-in got a hold of
me on Twitter yesterday afternoon and
actually gave me access to the slack
channel for this for this plug-in and
offered to to talk to me and even
potentially talk on the stream and
explain more about the plug-in and how
to use it so I'll reach out to him and
it's his name's Jason ball so I'll reach
out to Jason and just kind of ask him
what's up with the new version and and
how do I get it working and then and
we'll get that all sorted up and I also
think I'm gonna submit a pull request to
update the documentation a little bit
because I we had a little bit of trouble
in trying to get that to work yesterday
I don't think the documentation needs a
lot of work in terms of my documentation
I mean the stuff that they have in the
readme on github the actual
documentation you click you can click
through to get to their site on is it's
not bad but some of the stuff in the
video I think would be good to have in
the in the readme in the github repo
okay
so let's do that so anyway thanks are
[ __ ] for for all the info as well it's
like saving me so much time of
troubleshooting so let's bring in I
gotta go to my terminal first should we
merge this now or should we just keep
words so I made another branch called
Note redux I guess I don't have to merge
it right now during the stream but I'm
just thinking are we 100% sure you know
we want to go with this and we won't
want to go back to what we had before
I'm pretty sure that we want to go with
this but I'll hold off and merge it
later for now I guess we can install
this as well
that's interesting
I don't think I've ever brought in a
Google font with NPM I'd like to try it
though
okay so we're going to try to bring this
in and then we can just import this into
our route component and then I I suppose
we'll be able to use it so that's seems
convenient give it a shot
okay and where's our app touch yes we'll
bring it in here
okay
all right so let's we'll just put in
just very basic stuff how to get started
so just make sure yeah that's it that's
all for installation and
interesting so they have a create react
app example
okay so nothing there
to death
hmm
it's interesting this is definitely
different than than the other version
that we had used all right so let's just
bring in let's bring you some components
that we know we'll need so we'll
definitely need that top at bar
here we go so let's bring that in to get
nuts
okay yeah so this is what we'll want and
Wow quite a bit okay
all right let's bring that into we don't
want to nap Jess let's put it in home I
eventually at some point we'll probably
have a layout component so we don't have
to bring this in all the time or you
know but for now I don't mind doing it
like this just to make it make it easy
to adjust until we get it to a point
where you know we really like how it
looks so let me listen for now okay I
thought I had pasted that copy something
different let me bring this in now let's
see there
let's see if we won okay yeah let's
bring these in first
all right so hopefully our app will look
a little bit more exciting here in a
minute thanks let's do that a bit
I'd say that and see if we get errors
yeah classes is not defined that when
you find
oops and pace practice
all right let's see if we get it now
all right so we're getting some errors
and you can see if you if you've clicked
on the the n grok length in them you
could probably see these as well we'll
just go through some of these errors 935
all right so we're getting miss there we
go that's what I missed
I'm sure somebody in the lab had already
caught that
how about I just
hooves
so this is not to find where we
what did I just do I took out the wrong
thing button app bar is not this
I'll put it I put it in the right spot
oh you know what I didn't did I yeah
see if we Stuart
no we do in fact need that let me check
the hi chefs
oh did I not bring in I think I need to
bring in prop types I'm pretty sure we
don't
right didn't prop types you used to be a
part of react and then now now you
actually have to bring them in correct
okay
let's give this another shot
hmm
wait a second huh oh my goodness all
right I feel really silly right now
obviously because the components name is
button a part and this okay all right oh
my goodness
so we don't even really need that but
just to get it to work let's what you
know you're happy
yes
I'm pretty sure we got pretty much
everything from this
all right how are we going to do this
all right
okay question alright so it seems like
I've missed this here at the bottom we
have to do you know we have to say which
style styles and then button at bar but
how do we combine that with what we're
doing here
I seriously doubt
see
I thought we could just put them
side-by-side I mean I guess it's worth a
shot
we're already getting there there's no
way that's gonna work let's see what we
get
yeah it's not gonna work I'm gonna make
this work
you didn't wrap it with him Eli provided
that let's see
yeah I don't think we needed to I mean
let me check this example again see what
they did here yeah so they've wrapped
they didn't wrap the root component in
anything there you can check our pages
shoot they did here
see if he did
who
I could try to do it sir alright so hard
[ __ ] put in the in the live chat try it
like this
but I've we're still not we still don't
have styles in there let's see what
happens
hmm
okay so when we do it like that we're
not getting the the post spec I don't
know I'm thinking about just going back
to the old material you are again let's
see
see what they're doing for the
components
Oh
so this is where they're wrapping the
the theme and everything
the
all right I definitely don't have enough
time in this pumping or a session to
deal with this okay hmm
okay I still have to look into that let
me know what you think though because
I'm about to do a question and answers
is it worth it to try to do the latest
version of material UI or should I just
go back to the old version that we've
used before potentially just waiting
until it's not in beta anymore and then
using it let's see then I go back I try
to get back to see what version run
yeah we're it's still in beta okay
anyway let me know about that so I'm
gonna switch over to the question and
answer session
so yes so if you can stick around for
your question answer session and even if
you don't have a question you can help
answer questions that would be awesome
would definitely value your opinion
otherwise thanks for watching it was
kind of a mixed bag today I had some
cool stuff with with Apollo and getting
things to work not I didn't really do
much
Harshit did most of the work and then
completely failed and trying to get the
new version of material material UI it's
a work but hopefully hopefully it'll be
better on Monday anyway let's get
started I'm gonna scroll up and pick up
where I left off answering questions
alright okay so Brett says it's graph Q
I'm making a second API call to get the
featured image and that Kevin responded
the featured image link is fetched in
the single API request but the actual
image is loaded in a different request
started by the image tag okay that makes
sense
Brett says says my fetch calls only have
the ID of the featured image in there
the WordPress REST API and have to make
another call to get the image URL yeah
so yeah that is interesting so that's
true in the with the REST API you don't
actually get the image URL by default
with the post so you can get a plug-in
that will give you that data or you can
make a second API calls since you will
have the the image ID but let's see what
we're getting yeah let's see what we're
getting with that one call my queries
you know it's not working because of
error let's go back I'm just gonna take
a lot of this out of here just so we can
get something that works
okay now let's see if we can get this so
let's run this so this is the get all
post query and we can see the data that
we're getting back let's just get rid of
this the day that we're getting back
does have the source URL so probably
what's happening is that the way that
this plug-in is built to get the data
from WordPress is it does actually give
you the URL so it's a little a little
different than the WordPress API which I
mean this actually makes a lot of sense
I I read some issues and the reasoning
on why they didn't include the URL in
the post but it I don't know it seems to
me like the URL is so much more useful
than the image ID like why wouldn't you
want that included with you know the
post request but anyway but that is
there so you don't need a second API
call
so Marco says so basically when using
graph QL with Redux and Apollo I can
just remove Redux from my project it
seems it seems like you could there
potentially depending on how complex
your project is there may be some
reasons for using it I would think
there's probably some things that you
would want hmm sorry there's probably
some things that you would want globally
available in the store that you're not
necessarily getting from graph QL in
that case then I think you know maybe
you would want to use Redux
with with Apollo with graph QL unless
there's some way using Apollo to add
things to the store now they're
necessarily being dated you know that
you get from graphic UL I don't know yet
I haven't got that far with it
okay so we had a question earlier from
Rolando about resources for learning
react and Marco says traversée media is
a great channel to learn react so I
haven't seen anything from traversée
media myself but I guess check it out
Marco says they're good resource
fairest Moss says why do you guys keep
labeling these as with react shouldn't
it be with webcam or something um any
Kevin responds react is a JavaScript
framework or library I'm with you there
Kevin I always go back and forth on
calling things frameworks and libraries
but anyway reactors JavaScript framework
created by Facebook to make web
development easier
jesse is using it in this project so and
Ferris says okay thank you for
clarifying that yeah I guess that's if
you're not familiar with the names of
the technologies that we're using the
titles of these videos are probably Oh
nonsense
I mean you just can't explain everything
in a title so sorry about that
okay no beers here it says sorry I've
been busy busy for last two weeks so
that I can't watch your live session oh
it's cool no beer don't worry about it I
mean we definitely like to have you
around for the live session but I
totally understand if you can't be here
I know I'm super busy all the time if I
couldn't do these live sessions at work
then there's no way I'd be able to do it
for you know one to two hours every
every weekday so totally understand
about being busy let's see fastest on e
says semicolon is missing no actually I
don't use semicolons normally it looked
weird for for a few minutes there
because I was copy and pasting in code
that was using semicolons so it it
probably looked a mess but kevin says
semicolons are never missing unless you
miss them
I like that Kevin s yeah so you don't
really need semicolons I know there's
some case and I know we've had it before
in the live chat where it would might
mess things up if you don't use a
semicolon but I can't remember that
cases offhand but I remember thinking
wow I've never had that particular case
come up for me so most of the time
you're alright with leaving out
semicolons but we are accepting of
different coding styles here on the free
code camp live stream so if you like
semicolons that's cool and you can hang
out with us too and if you don't like
semicolons then that's cool too I don't
think it matters that much as long as
you're as long as your code works I
think that's more important
okay and actually I got through all the
the questions so must be it's a slow day
here with actually I just checked
assuming my analytics are right now we
do have a lot less viewers than normal
so that would explain why there is not
as much activity in the live chat we did
get one more question so John Hanson
says I read that full understanding of
JavaScript isn't needed to work and
react as it's a library to me it still
feels too much a mystery it does things
like magic at times is it better to
build my es6 first hmm
knowledge of es6 definitely helped me
with react but I don't know this is
necessary like there's always gonna be
some magic
I have heard I've heard the argument
before that like you got to really
understand what's going on I mean I used
to hear years ago when I mean jQuery is
still a big thing but before react was
really big I guess I would I was more
into jQuery and I would hear people say
you know you really should read the
source code for jQuery and understand
how it works behind the scenes and I
mean that's okay but to me it's like
jQuery was awesome starting out because
you didn't have to know how it all
worked it just worked and you could use
it so if if you go behind the scenes and
read everything and how would they do it
it was jQuery then why not just write it
in vanilla JavaScript and not import all
of jQuery if you know how to do it so I
don't necessarily agree with that
argument if if your goal is to learn how
everything works in and out then yeah go
for it but if your goal is just to make
things that work you don't need to know
all the magic behind the scenes if you
do would you be better at it probably
there's definitely in particular what
- - performance so if you don't
understand things right behind the
scenes you may not realize why doing
things one way is you know way more
performant than knowing them another way
right because you don't know what's
going on you just do something and it
works right so when it comes down to
things like that
a better understanding will definitely
help but you know we're talking about
usually with those questions the
difference of milliseconds on small
projects that's not a big deal I mean if
you're not working on really huge
projects you know all that adds up and
you know you really you know if saving a
few milliseconds makes a big difference
saving a little bit of you know
computing time makes a big difference
but if you're just starting out in
building some projects with react and
they're not huge and they're not you
know not really important in the sense
that like a lot of people are dependent
on it for let's say like banking or
medical things or things that you know
potentially could have a huge impact on
people's lives then I I say don't worry
about it you know you can use it as long
as you can use it enough to build
something with I don't think there's
there's anything wrong with that and
then as you use it your knowledge will
increase so I just say if you're going
to use it and you're not confident in
your knowledge of es6 or of other
JavaScript just make sure that you build
up that knowledge as you go I think it
would it would be wrong to just try to
do reactant and never try to learn
although I think it would be really hard
to do react and not learn more about
JavaScript as you're doing it I think
that just it just happens naturally as
you learn to do more things with react
so anyway that's my opinion about it I
know people would disagree cuz I've read
and heard other opinions about that but
there's something to be said for the
confidence builder of actually making
things making things that work and are
cool you know at some point you just got
to take that step and just start using
things trying them out yeah maybe you
don't understand completely how it works
but
like you don't need to I mean we don't
really need to you know you don't write
you don't need to know everything about
electricity and how it works to be able
to use you know a computer or I mean
think about all the things that go into
a computer working we don't need to know
all that stuff or does that do you know
all the NPM packages that you have going
on behind the scenes and how they work
no of course not
right if somebody did know all that
stuff could they make something that's
really performant probably but that's
just it's just crazy to learn all that
so at some point you have to say you
know what I'm you know here's where my
skill level is at right now I'm gonna do
what I can with this and I'll learn as I
go along anyway that kind of turned into
a rant a little bit at the end so a husk
sorry about that but anyway so I would
say don't be afraid to try out react and
do some things with it and you'll pick
up what you need to pick up as you go
along let's see John Hanson says true
thanks problem is there's too much poor
documentation waste people saw problem
solved with examples it's hard to sister
yeah definitely I agree yeah from that
from that perspective it can be really
hard to learn things with react if
you're not familiar with es6 and you see
all these examples with es6 in them then
you you really have two issues one like
you know I haven't saved since Monday
yeah I think I saved on Monday and then
didn't save possibly Saturday I can't
remember I like sitting down to Shaving
like once a week now I've just gotten
really lazy about it
it's alright I mean luckily where I work
there's no real policy on whether or not
you have a beer to shave or anything
like that so I could grow a giant bushy
beard if I wanted to
uh-huh but my wife wouldn't like that
she's not a fan of the beard okay
Oh horseshit says we'll be making
another pool with the Mui awesome
actually horseshit if you do that I'm
going to be so happy if you get this
this material you guys stuff working
yeah I'll be awesome let's see okay well
now I've again gotten to the bottom of
the live chat so I guess I'm gonna go
for real this time
and I had a great time talking to you
all so the actual coding portion of it
for me was a bit disappointing just
because my contributions all didn't work
uh-huh but I did like the
question-and-answer I enjoyed talking
with you all I mean I really talked a
lot but I like the questions that we had
so it's Friday we got a nice weekend
coming up and I'll be back on Monday but
a Sebastian's here yeah you're late
Sebastian I started early
so you missed missed it basically if you
want to know what we did this session
check out pool request one on project
four on the the react bulletin project
because the thing that harsh the stuff
that Harsha did in full request one is
pretty much all that I got to work today
everything I tried did not work so she
didn't miss much there okay John Hanson
says it's Thanksgiving holiday in Canada
this weekend so happy Thanksgiving to
you Jesse awesome Happy Thanksgiving
so yes everyone oh my
their neighbors in Canada have a happy
Thanksgiving this weekend
cool all right yeah so everybody have a
great weekend especially those in Canada
I have a great holiday weekend and I'll
be back Monday and hopefully I'll have a
more successful a time one one day but
sorry I couldn't find the button to end
this dream so I was just kind of
stalling all right but anyway have a
great weekend I see you all on Monday